Почав потроху за стінку триматися. Ну і рівновагу потроху-потроху. Намагаюся сильно не навантажувати, там ще ранки є.
Микита Горбань вчиться ходити на ногах без пальців. У такому стані він повернувся з російського полону.
Микита ніколи не тримав у руках зброї, він медик. Коли росіяни вторглися на Київщину, залишився з родиною у селі Андріївка, за 50 кілометрів від Києва.
На початку березня чоловіка і його вітчима забрали росіяни. Тримали надворі, із зав'язаними очима.
Катували, добре катували. Руки ключем виламували, пальці. Мені і йому. Йому взагалі палець відірвали.
Зараз уже пришили на місце, все добре. Катували, били. Зі зброї біля вуха стріляли, чого тільки не було.
Питали, де артилерія стоїть, аби хоч щось із нас вибити.
Змусили зняти взуття, ми в калошах були, налили туди води. А там ще така погода була, що сніг ішов, якісь опади були. Я отримав обмороження.
У тих самих калошах Микиту повезли спершу в Білорусь, потім до Курська.
Без належної медичної допомоги пальці на ногах почали гнити, а потім буквально відпадати, каже чоловік.
Ампутацію провели в Курську - після трьох тижнів після обмороження.
Наприкінці квітня Микиту і ще кілька десятків українців обміняли на російських військових.
Це складно було емоційно. Феєрверк просто. До останньої секунди не вірив. Везуть та й везуть, куди везуть - я вже навчений, нікому не вірю.
А тут привезли, і я почув фразу "З поверненням, друже". І тоді я зрозумів, що я вже вдома.
Нині Микита на реабілітації в рідній лікарні, там, де працював лаборантом до війни.
Він не знаходить пояснень, чому його взяли в полон і яку інформацію хотіли з нього вибити росіяни. Але розуміє, чому відправили на обмін.
Саме через травму. Бо хто нас буде в такий час утримувати? Це ж годувати, й місце займати, це ж теж розуміти треба.
Хто нас буде обслуговувати? Тим паче нас багато. Повернули й добре. Виходить, як квиток додому, - ніжки. Дорогий квиток.
На окупованих територіях російські військові регулярно викрадають голів ОТГ, міських рад, активістів або й звичайних громадян.
Попри те, що взяття в заручники цивільних - грубе порушення міжнародного права.
Це примусове позбавлення волі, такий самий злочин, як будь-який інший злочин - зґвалтування чи мародерство і так далі.
І тут у нас є ще інша історія - Росія вважає всіх цивільних осіб такими, що сприяють нашій армії,
розглядають їх як некомбатантів, як військовополонених, і потім починають обмінювати на тих самих умовах, що і військовослужбовців.
На цьому відео - українські військові з "Азовсталі", які фактично потрапили в російський полон.
Під контролем росіян їх роздягають, оглядають, усе показово знімають на відео.
У Держдумі Росії навіть лунають заклики до страти військових із полку "Азов".
Юристи наголошують: за Женевською конвенцією 1949 року, до військовополонених належить ставитися
гуманно й не виставляти на показ заради "цікавості публіки".
А судити полонених можна лише, коли є докази вчинення ними воєнних злочинів.
На думку юриста-міжнародника Євгена Крапивіна, у випадку захисників Маріуполя таких доказів немає.
Якщо особа не вчиняла воєнні злочини, а просто виконувала накази, то вона володіє так званим імунітетом або привілеєм комбатанта.
Тобто якщо ти маєш наказ обороняти місто, або зайняти якісь позиції, чи знищувати ворога,
і це не відбувається із застосуванням заборонених методів війни, з насильницькими діями стосовно цивільного населення і так далі,
то це все знімає відповідальність за те, що в мирний час називалось би злочином.
В Україні вже відбувся перший судовий процес над полоненим росіянином.
21-річному Вадиму Шишимаріну присудили довічне ув'язнення за вбивство мирного жителя Сумщини -
це воєнний злочин. Російський військовий сам зізнався у вчиненому.
Я щиро розкаююся. У той момент я нервував, коли це все сталося, були бойові дії. І я не хотів убивати постраждалого.
Але так сталося, і я від цього не відмовляюся.
Для України свідчення й зізнання полонених росіян - шанс притягти до відповідальності винних у скоєнні воєнних злочинів не заочно, а очно.
Для блогера Володимира Золкіна спілкування з полоненими - інструмент інформаційної війни.
Із дозволу МВС він записав уже сотні інтерв'ю з росіянами.
Він звертається до них на "ви", питає про згоду на зйомку і публікацію, наприкінці дає можливість поговорити з близькими.
Для багатьох полонених, каже Золкін, - це єдина можливість повідомити, що вони живі.
Сину, тебе вже тут поховали кілька разів. (плаче) - Цього я найбільше боявся.
Більшість героїв інтерв'ю блогера нині найбільше переймаються про те, що на них чекає вдома, після обміну.
Хоча раніше не піддавали сумніву російську пропаганду.
Якщо у нас були біологічно чи хімічно заражені пташки, яких ми збиралися відправити в Росію, чому до сих пір не відправили? -
… Та немає тому що їх, мабуть, цих пташок.
Жодного, який би побувши тут, побачивши це все на власні очі, побачивши ставлення, поспілкувавшись з українцями,
жодного не лишається, який би сказав, що за його ідеєю щось було. Тому що я ж задаю ці питання: чому ти йшов?
Ну, тому що нам по телевізору розповідали про НАТО, біолабораторії, нацистів.
Ну, а я питаю: що з цієї інформації підтвердилося? Нічого не підтвердилося.
Володимир Золкін вірить, що вустами російських полонених він зможе переконати принаймні їхніх родичів і знайомих в Росії у безглуздості війни.
Коли це слухають люди, які збираються або збиралися сюди їхати, або родичі цих людей, то на них це діє інакше.
Вони про це не говорять, вони не вийдуть на вулицю, не скажуть про це, вони не скажуть про це на телебаченні російському.
Але вони тихенько скажуть своєму Івану: "Ваня, не їдь.
Горілки там немає, нічого цікавого ти там не знайдеш, мікрохвильовку купимо і так".
Десять росіян сюди не поїхали - принаймні одного українця не вбили, одну жінку не зґвалтували. Варто? Варто.
Належне утримання полонених - важливий елемент пропаганди, переконує і заступниця міністра юстиції Олена Висоцька.
Ми збережемо життя нашим військовим тим, що, можливо, якщо в полоні не так страшно, то та сторона десь не ризикуючи життям буде легше,
більше здаватися в полон. Військовополонені Російської Федерації не утримуються в таких умовах,
як наші полонені на окупованих територіях або на території РФ. Це небо і земля.
За даними мін'юсту, лише на харчування, одяг, засоби гігієни і комунальні платежі для одного полоненого потрібно 3000 гривень на місяць.
Також є витрати на медичне обладнання, ліки, зарплату персоналу. Утім, на думку Олени Висоцької, витрати виправдані.
Ми тільки військовим хочемо говорити про те, що ваша справа вправно воювати, і якщо виходить брати в полон - беріть,
для нас це дуже важливо, тому що це майбутнє врятоване життя ваших побратимів, тому що це обмінний фонд, який використовується у переговорах.
Усе це, звісно, наші витрати, але, повірте, виправдані - порівняно з тим, яку користь ми отримуємо, рятуючи життя наших військовополонених.
Скільки в Україні полонених росіян - не публічна інформація.
До того ж, ця цифра постійно змінюється - регулярно відбуваються обміни. Ідеться про сотні, кажуть у мін'юсті.
Їх утримують у тюрмах, але окремо від інших ув'язнених. Спорудили вже перший табір, розрахований на 500 людей.
У профільному міністерстві запевняють: роблять усе, аби виконати вимоги Женевської конвенції про захист військовополонених.
В українському уряді говорять, що це їхня місія - показати світу, чим Україна відрізняється від Росії.